the jurgen experience but again what
else are you gonna do
so so tiger king killed some time and
then the aftermath of tiger king killed
some more time
but then we still got like six more
weeks so what do we do now
i think we're supposed to be may 15th
right may 15th it's gonna be that's the
yeah i think that's the latest projected
date but the governor just stopped
people
from going to the parks and beaches well
that was a new uh
thing today yeah i think you know you
know what it is this is my theory
like you we can't have nice things you
know whenever they give us something
nice we don't know
you know like a little kid [ __ ]
something nice and they break so it's
like okay
we're gonna let you go to the beach it's
like no you're not supposed to be
playing volleyball and laying like like
just you're supposed to keep moving
right you're supposed to like
walk or ride a bike or go surf or this
but you weren't supposed to just
mingle gathering groups and of course
we're gathering groups with partying
they're like all right no you can't
you don't have a specific rules like you
weren't allowed to stay put
like you couldn't lean on things
couldn't sit down right because
you go walk around i was riding i wrote
i rode my motorcycle along pch
and you would see people they park their
car along pch
right and they'd sit on the car and kind
of like look at the beach and stuff like
and
so i guess you each one of them had
a car's distance between them because
you're sitting on your car the next
person sitting on their car
but then i passed this um neptune's net
which is like a
big motorcycle hangout and there were
maybe 20 bikes in a row parked
and the guys were all just kind of
hanging out and it was like no man like
that you can't do that you know i mean
like like a motorcycle is the ultimate
social distancing vehicle right you're
you're by yourself you're wearing a
jacket gloves a helmet you're not
breathing on anybody
but when you stop you can't just all
hang out like normal you know and that
that was the part that uh
that i think that that's where they're
like no we're not gonna do it because
i think you know this georgia and
florida whatever
it's like they're like the experiment
man they're like all right yeah let's
let them get out
and then let's wait two weeks and see
what happens yeah exactly
you know that's exactly what it's like
[Applause]
you